I'm Katherine Kwan,
and I'm a developer advocate at Google.
I started off by working as an engineer
on the Android apps team.
I worked there for three years on
products like Google Play and Google Keep,
the note taking app.
I'm continually blown away
by what you can build on this platform,
and I'm particularly inspired
by those apps that can truly improve
people's lives.
When I meet people, they often tell me
about their great app ideas.
But then they feel like they don't have
the technical skills to actually build it.
And that's why I shifted over
to developer relations
so I can help people like you
really build something great.
Throughout this course, I'll be helping
you implement your very first app.
My name is Dan Gauthan.
I've been a developer advocate at Google
for four years and I've worn
a lot of hats here.
My goal is to keep us on track
to make Sunshine, something that
had some resemblance
to a production quality app.
I'll introduce Android design
patterns and principles.
Many of which are often missed
by new Android developers.
You'll learn to lean on the framework,
focusing on what makes your app unique
instead of reinventing the wheel.
I'm Rado Mya, and I've been a developer
advocate for Android at Google
for five years.
I started working on Androids
so long ago that back then
there were no devices.
All we had to work with
were an emulator, a beater SDK,
and an almost fanatical devotion
to the platform.
I'll be joining you from here,
my underground Android developer bunker,
and my goal isn't to get you up
and running as quickly as possible.
It's to teach you the context behind
the choices we'll make.
And the best practices you need,
to really understand how to create
great experiences specifically
tailored to mobile devices.
By the time you finished this course
you'll know more than just how to create
yet another app.
You'll know how to build
great apps that focus on the user.